impfpflicht ja oder nein
wie positionieren sie sich
mainz/berlin ich positionieren mich so
dass ich glaube dass wir eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 18 jahren brauchen werden
weil die impfquote nicht hoch genug ist
und wir haben ja die situation gehabt
dass vor einer weile viele menschen
krank geworden sind gestorben sind weil
wir kein impfstoff hatten jetzt sterben
menschen und müssen menschen sterben
weil wir in dem kohle nicht hoch genug
ist und deswegen glaube ich ins bei
aller schwierige abwägungen die wir
haben bei uns ist ein eingriff in
grundrechte richtig aber der staat ist
auch zuständig dafür leben und
gesundheit von menschen zu schützen das
können wir am besten wenn sich möglichst
viele kämpfen dass die impfquote ist zu
niedrig und deswegen trete ich nach
abwägung der argumente dafür ein das ist
eine allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 jahre
machen um den gesundheitsschutz zu
verbessern und endlich aus dieser
pandemie auch raus zu kommen was ich
millionen menschen wünschen die endlich
die freiheitsbeschränkung loswerden
wollen
also ich glaube ich wertschätze das
motiv dass endlich die anderen maßnahmen
wird können ich folge nicht der
argumentation einer allgemeinen der
notwendigkeit eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für menschen über 18 weil
mir wirklich nicht einleuchtet warum man
einen 22-jährigen kern gesunden menschen
ohne irgendwelche vorerkrankungen dazu
zwingen sollte sich impfen zu lassen das
ist in keiner weise verhältnismäßig das
ist nicht verhältnismäßig medizinisch
das ist nicht verhältnismäßig was
mögliche im folgen angeht das ist nicht
verhältnismäßig was die belegung der
intensivstationen angeht da landet der
24 22 20 jährigen nämlich auf gar keinen
fall und es ist auch nicht
verhältnismäßig im vorgenannten sinne
dass nämlich nicht alles versucht worden
ist den oder diejenige zum impfen ohne
zwang zu animieren und jetzt ist von mir
das böse wort zwang gefallen da meinen
politiker immer es ist kein zwang und so
ich erinnere an das geschwurbel des
bundesgesundheitsministers dass es sich
um so eine art freiwilligen zwang
handelt das spürt man ja schon dass
selbst die die in der verantwortung
stehen den glauben an die unbedingte
notwendigkeit einer impfpflicht verloren
haben jetzt nur ihre positionen nicht
räumen wollen um nicht zum zweiten mal
die 180 grad wende einzuleiten nämlich
ich war erst dagegen gegen die
impfpflicht dann war ich dafür und jetzt
bin ich wieder dagegen das gute an zwei
mal 180 grad ist aber dass man wieder an
den ausgangspunkt ankommt und der war
richtig
also ich akzeptiere herr stolz dass es
mängel gegeben hat bei dem werben für
das empfindliche akzeptiere im übrigen
auch das argument dass man immer prüfen
muss ob man bürgerrechte einschränken
kann und sagt sogar die
verhältnismäßigkeit sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass wir zwei jahre lang schon
die bürgerrechte in einer form
einschränkt ist als 70 jahren nicht
gegeben hat mit ausgangssperren mit
allen möglichen beschränkungen wehren
uns mit masken vor zwei jahren
betrachtet hätte hätte es als für den
horrorfilm gehalten und dass die
belastung auch die betreffen und zwar
sehr stark die kaum gefährdet sind wie
die kinder und jugendlichen ganz stark
getroffen wenn wir rausholen aus der
situation dann glaube ich schon dass wir
eine höhere impfquote brauchen weil ja
die zahlen doch sehr deutlich sind
schauen sich sachsen zum beispiel an
niedrigen quote höchste sterbezahlen pro
kopf der bevölkerung und dass es
anderswo auch festzustellen das ist
nicht kein optimales mittel sicherlich
nicht essen freiheitseinschränkung aber
nach abwägung der dinge glaube ich ist
das eine vernünftige maßnahme und wir
müssen ja viele dinge übrigens machen
die uns nicht gefallen was das thema
zwang es gibt viele leute die gegen
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen sind es
gibt auch leute die mögen keine roten
ampeln und da steht uns auch nicht über
ein polizist annehmen aber trotzdem wird
das gehandelt wenn man dagegen verstößt
und deswegen glaube ich schon dass das
eine zumutbare belastung ist und sie
haben auch nicht ganz recht mit dem
hinweis jugendliche würden gar nicht
betroffen sind und junge menschen es
gibt sehr wohl welche mit lang en wid es
gibt auch welche die ernsthafter krank
es gibt sogar tote weniger aber die gibt
es auch und wir haben einfach schon so
viel hinter uns sind menschen einsam
gestorben die leute schuften auf den
pflegestationen dass die kamera aus den
augen gucken sie schützen leute übrigens
die sie verspotten teilweise weil sie
gesagt haben es gibt doch gar nicht die
krankheit und ich will auch sagen wir
haben eine sehr respektable der debatte
im deutschen bundestag heute ist ganz
vernünftig im wald zwischen den meisten
außerdem rechtsradikalen die hier
auftreten und eigentlich die demokratie
angreifen wollen und deswegen glaube ich
sollten wir es nicht zu einer frage
machen die pro oder contra demokratie
sind dazu eine wo man ohne welche
meinung haben kann auch eine
gewissensentscheidung treffen kann aber
wo die mehrheit der bevölkerung ich
glaube die große mehrheit der
bevölkerung am ende ist richtig finden
wird wie wir verfahren deswegen glaube
ich auch noch große mehrheit im
bundestag geben für ein pflichtfach sind
eine sache wird mich noch interessieren
jetzt eher als bürger wer ist ihnen denn
wirklich möglich gegen die impfpflicht
zu sein obwohl ihr bundeskanzler dafür
ist ihr
bundesgesundheitsminister dafür ist wenn
ich sage ihr meine ich ebenfalls spd
politiker obwohl eine mutmassliche
mehrheit in ihrer fraktion dafür ist
hätten sie den mut zu sagen ich bin
dagegen oder ist es trotzdem so was wie
ein indirekter fraktionszwang obwohl man
doch nur seinem gewissen verpflichtet
ist
also wer den stegen r kennt der weiß
dass ich nicht zu den feucht samen
menschen gehör und meine man immer sagen
abgesehen davon dass natürlich auch in
unserer fraktion menschen gibt die gegen
allgemeine impfpflicht sind so wie in
den anderen fraktionen auch und das ist
übrigens auch legitim solange man nicht
mit rechtsradikalen argumenten kommt
zweifel dass die krankheit überhaupt
gibt und so was finde ich kann man über
jedes argument streiten alle mal über
das der verhältnismäßigkeit und dann
kann jeder seine meinung sagen ich tue
das auch tun das auch in anderen fragen
und also angst kriege ich mit 62 jahren
nicht mehr davor man muss keine meinung
verwenden ist es meine überrascht und
ich wollte das auch noch mal sagen wegen
der 180 grad wende wenn man feststellt
dass man falsch liegt es ist klüger
seine meinung zu ändern als halsstarrig
bei dem zu bleiben was man gedacht hat
ich dachte kunden darunter kunsthalle
höher sei nur ein aspekt kommt
das kann gut sein aber streiten könnten
demokratin jetzt ist dass du meine güte
nur in der demokratie und deswegen
kritisiere ich auch all die die
behaupten wir hätten keine mehr wir
haben meinungsfreiheit wir haben
demokratie die sollten wir auch
verteidigen auch in dem wir
leidenschaftlich streiten über den
richtigen weg unbedingt
das war das streitgespräch hierbei bild
live danke ralf stegner dass sie
mitgemacht haben mitten während dieser
spannende debatte hinter ihnen dort im
plenarsaal sie gehen wieder zurück
dorthin danke dass sie bei uns waren
danke auch dir klaus wild life für den
moment